Why would someone lie about being sick or do terrible things to themselves in order to appear sick? Factitious disorder, more commonly known as Munchausen syndrome, is a mental health disorder in which people fake serious illness in order to gain sympathy, attention, and support. A related disorder, Munchausen by proxy, or a factitious disorder imposed on another, is a form of abuse in which caregivers, often mothers of young children, make up or even induce illness in their kids. This is to gain sympathy and support. How common are these disorders? Why do they go by so many different names?
为什么有人会假装生病，或者为了让自己看起来生病而对自己做出可怕的事情？虚假障碍，也就是俗称的孟乔森综合征，是一种心理健康疾病，患者会伪装成患有严重疾病，以获得同情、关注和支持。而与之相关的一种疾病是代理性孟乔森综合征，或者叫施加于他人的虚假障碍，这是一种虐待形式，照顾者（通常是幼儿的母亲）会捏造甚至诱发孩子的病情。这是为了获得同情和支持。这些疾病有多常见？为什么它们有这么多不同的名字？
What's the difference between factitious disorder or Munchausen syndrome and simply malingering? Are factitious disorders related to other mental health disorders? Are there effective therapies? Can a person with factitious disorder be cured of it? And what about people who lie to strangers on the Internet about being sick? Is that a form of one of these disorders as well? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
虚假障碍或孟乔森综合征与单纯的诈病有什么区别？虚假障碍与其他心理健康疾病有关吗？有有效的治疗方法吗？患有虚假障碍的人能治愈吗？那些在互联网上向陌生人谎称自己生病的人呢？这也是其中一种疾病的形式吗？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Mark Feldman, a board-certified psychiatrist, clinical professor of psychiatry, and adjunct professor of psychology at the University of Alabama. He is an international expert in factitious disorder, Munchausen syndrome, Munchausen by proxy, and Malingering. He has authored more than 100 research studies and five books on these topics, including his most recent book, Dying to Be Ill, True Stories of Medical Deception. Dr. Feldman is a distinguished fellow, of the American Psychiatric Association and has spoken to dozens of media outlets about Munchausen syndrome.
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天请到了两位嘉宾。首先是马克·费尔德曼博士（Dr. Mark Feldman），他是一位获得委员会认证的精神病学家、精神病学临床教授，也是阿拉巴马大学的心理学兼职教授。他是虚假障碍、孟乔森综合征、代理性孟乔森综合征和诈病领域的国际专家。他撰写了100多项研究报告和五本关于这些主题的书籍，其中包括他最新出版的书《渴望生病：医疗欺骗的真实故事》（Dying to Be Ill, True Stories of Medical Deception）。费尔德曼博士是美国精神病学协会的杰出资深会员，曾就孟乔森综合征接受过数十家媒体的采访。
Our second guest is Dr. Janet Cahill, a clinical psychologist and professor emerita in the Department of Psychology at Rowan University. Her private practice specializes in assessing abused and neglected children and their families, including evaluations and treatments for factitious disorder imposed on another, or Munchausen by proxy. Dr. Cahill has consulted with many human services agencies, including the New Jersey Division of Child Permanency and Protection, the Nevada Division of Child and Family Services, and the South Carolina and Colorado Departments of Child Protective Services. She also provides workshops and training to human services professionals. Thank you both for joining me today. It's a pleasure.
我们的第二位嘉宾是珍妮特·卡希尔博士（Dr. Janet Cahill），她是一位临床心理学家，也是罗文大学心理学系的荣誉退休教授。她的私人诊所专门评估受虐待和忽视的儿童及其家庭，包括对施加于他人的虚假障碍（即代理性孟乔森综合征）的评估和治疗。卡希尔博士曾为许多人类服务机构提供咨询，包括新泽西州儿童永久安置与保护局、内华达州儿童与家庭服务局以及南卡罗来纳州和科罗拉多州的儿童保护服务部门。她还为人类服务专业人员提供研讨会和培训。非常感谢两位今天做客节目。我的荣幸。
Thank you. In the introduction, I mentioned that these disorders are known by several different names. Factitious disorder is the official term that's used in the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders, but most people, if they've heard of this disorder, are more familiar with the term Munchausen syndrome. And factitious disorder imposed on another, or Munchausen by proxy, is also sometimes called medical child abuse. Are these terms basically interchangeable? What's the history of these terms? And which do you use for which? Dr. Feldman, maybe you want to grab this one first. Yeah, there's been a lot of complexity because so many terms have been used to refer somewhat to munchausen syndrome, that is, people making themselves sick or lying a bad illness, but really to munchausen by proxy, which I do prefer to call medical child abuse. And the reason I prefer that is it focuses on the fact that this is abuse.
谢谢。在介绍中，我提到这些疾病有几个不同的名字。虚假障碍是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》中使用的官方术语，但大多数人如果听说过这种疾病，对“孟乔森综合征”这个词会更熟悉。而施加于他人的虚假障碍（或代理性孟乔森综合征）有时也被称为医疗儿童虐待。这些术语基本上可以互换吗？这些术语的历史是什么？你分别用哪个词来指代什么？费尔德曼博士，也许你想先回答这个问题。是的，这里面有很多复杂性，因为有太多的术语被用来多多少少地指代孟乔森综合征，也就是人们让自己生病或谎称自己得了重病，但实际上是指代理性孟乔森综合征，我更倾向于称之为医疗儿童虐待。我更喜欢这个词的原因是它聚焦于这是一个虐待事实的事实。
It typically involves a child being victimized. And it's easier to understand. Munchesom by proxy doesn't tell you very much about what the ailment is and what the behavior is, whereas medical child abuse makes it clear, and it also helps focus on the child victim rather than the adult perpetrator, who's usually the mother. But formally, the DSM-5 and DSM-5TR do call these factitious disorder imposed on self in the case of what we used to call Munchausen syndrome. And as you said, factitious disorder imposed on another for what people still tend to know is Munchausen by proxy. Dr. Cahill, does that resonate with you?
它通常涉及儿童沦为受害者。而且它更容易理解。代理性孟乔森综合征并没有告诉你太多关于病情和行为是什么的信息，而医疗儿童虐待则使其一目了然，它还有助于将重点放在儿童受害者身上，而不是通常是母亲的成年施暴者身上。但从形式上讲，DSM-5和DSM-5-TR确实将我们以前称之为孟乔森综合征的情况称为施加于自身的虚假障碍。正如你所说，对于人们仍然倾向于了解的代理性孟乔森综合征，则称为施加于他人的虚假障碍。卡希尔博士，这与你的看法产生共鸣吗？
Do you also use factitious disorder rather than Munchausen? So as a psychologist, I use factitious disorder imposed on another. And so that allows us to make that diagnosis. We're really looking at the same stuff, at the same symptoms, at the same problems. But our different professional needs are, if we're going to do it, we need to do it within our own areas. So I would use factitious disorder imposed on another. But honestly, for the most case, we're all looking at the same thing. Well, let me ask you the different.
你也用虚假障碍而不是孟乔森综合征吗？作为一名心理学家，我使用施加于他人的虚假障碍。这使我们能够做出这种诊断。我们实际上是在看同样的东西，同样的症状，同样的问题。但我们的不同专业需求是，如果我们要这样做，我们需要在自己的领域内完成。所以我会使用施加于他人的虚假障碍。但老实说，在大多数情况下，我们大家看到的都是同一件事。好吧，让我问你不同的地方。
between factitious disorders and simply malingering, which is basically faking or exaggerating illness, are there cases where people pretend to be sick but they don't have factitious disorder? Yeah, this can occur in, well, let me clarify the difference between factitious disorder and malingering, but also point out that they can coexist. Malingering involves external gains, primarily going after things that are tangible, like feigning or exaggerating illness or even inducing illness to get opioid medications or disability adjudications or not guilty by reason of insanity adjudications or evasion of military service. It's things that when you look at the patient situation, you can sort of understand why they've done what they've done. Whereas in factitious disorders in general, you have to infer psychological processes because they're after things like that aren't tangible, like intention, sympathy, care, and concern that they feel unable to get in other ways. But as I said, we all know motivations can shift over time. They can even coexist.
虚假障碍与单纯的诈病（基本上就是伪装或夸大病情）之间有什么区别？有没有这样一种情况：人们假装生病，但他们并没有患虚假障碍？是的，这种情况可能会发生，让我澄清一下虚假障碍和诈病之间的区别，但也指出它们可以共存。诈病涉及外部获得，主要是追求有形的东西，比如伪装、夸大病情甚至诱发疾病来获得阿片类药物药物、残志鉴定、因精神失常而无罪的裁决或逃避兵役。当你审视患者的情况时，你会发现这些事情是你可以理解他们为什么这样做的。而在虚假障碍中，总的来说，你必须推断心理过程，因为他们追求的是无形的东西，比如关注、同情、照顾和关心，而他们觉得无法通过其他方式获得这些。但正如我所说，我们都知道动机随着时间推移会发生变化。它们甚至可以共存。
And so I never hesitate to make the diagnosis of both if that's what's applicable in a given case. Dr. Cahill, let me ask you, how common do you think these disorders are? Do we have any reliable estimates? Well, by definition, an individual who meets the criteria for a factitious disorder is doing this on purpose for their own psychological needs. And so it's very, very hard to catch up with them. We have colleagues now who are doing some research on this. And the more we research it, the more we find it. So I think it's out there more than we expected, but it's also difficult to get a handle on it. I would just add that the recognition also has occurred that munchausen by proxy or factitious disorder imposed on another can also coexist with munchausen syndrome.
因此，如果特定病例适用的话，我绝不会犹豫同时做出这两种诊断。卡希尔博士，请问你认为这些疾病有多常见？我们有什么可靠的估计吗？嗯，根据定义，符合虚假障碍标准的个人是为了满足自己的心理需求而故意这样做的。因此，要追查到他们非常非常困难。我们现在有一些同行正在对此进行研究。我们研究得越多，发现的就越多。所以我认为这种情况比我们预期的要普遍，但也很难掌握其确切情况。我只想补充一点，人们也认识到，代理性孟乔森综合征或施加于他人的虚假障碍也可以与孟乔森综合征共存。
so somebody can be feigning illness in themselves and do it in a child as well. Sometimes we find that, and research has borne this out, up to a third of abusive moms in Munchesom biproxy cases have a personal history of feigning illness in themselves. And this is deliberate deception. They know what they're doing. There's often considerable planning involved in executing the behaviors that. deceptive behaviors. And so anyone who says, well, DSM contains these two diagnoses, the mothers can't, and patients can't be held responsible. No, this is deliberate behavior. And I always point out that
因此，一个人可能会在自己身上伪装疾病，同时也对孩子这样做。有时我们发现，研究也证实了这一点，在代理性孟乔森综合征病例中，多达三分之一的施虐母亲有在自己身上伪装疾病的个人历史。这是蓄意欺骗。他们知道自己在做什么。执行这些欺诈行为往往涉及相当多的策划。因此，任何人如果说，嗯，DSM包含了这两种诊断，母亲们不能，患者也不能承担责任。不，这是蓄意的行为。我总是指出，
pedophilia is also a mental disorder. But we certainly prosecute those who sexually abuse children. And sometimes we have to seriously look at prosecution in the Munchausen cases. especially medical child abuse or munchausen by proxy? It would seem that for someone to manifest either version of factitious disorders, that there must have been some kind of trauma, something happened in a person's life that led them to this behavior. One would think, how much is known about the causes of factitious disorder? Are there common threads?
恋童癖也是一种精神疾病。但我们肯定会起诉那些性虐待儿童的人。有时我们必须认真考虑在孟乔森综合征的案件中进行起诉。尤其是医疗儿童虐待或代理性孟乔森综合征？似乎对于表现出任何一种虚假障碍的人来说，一定经历过某种创伤，即一个人的生活中发生了某种事情，导致了他们这种行为。人们可能会想，人们对虚假障碍的原因了解多少？有什么共同的线索吗？
As Mark was saying, a lot of times they did this, they might have been the victims of that kind of behavior. They might have been exposed to it. So that's possibility. It might be trauma. But generally speaking, it's a psychological need that this parent has. Maybe it could be attention behavior. Maybe it could be they want to be seen as a fantastic mom.
正如马克所说，很多时候他们这样做，他们可能是这种行为的受害者。他们可能接触过这种行为。所以这是一种可能性。可能是创伤。但总的来说，这是这位父母的一种心理需求。也许可能是寻求关注的行为。也许可能是他们希望被视为一个了不起的母亲。
Maybe they have issues of control. They want to control everyone around them. So there's multiple paths to this. But a general way to think about it is this is a parent, and Mark is correct, it's almost all moms who are trying to get to, who are manipulating this child to meet their own psychological needs, whatever those are. Dr. Feldman, let me ask you, how difficult is it to diagnose factitious disorders? I mean, do you think that MDs are sufficiently aware of the syndromes so that they can spot it in patients?
也许他们有控制欲方面的问题。他们想控制周围的每个人。所以通往这条路的途径有很多。但总的来说，这是一个父母——马克说得对，几乎全都是母亲——试图通过操纵这个孩子来满足她们自己的心理需求，无论这些需求是什么。费尔德曼博士，请问诊断虚假障碍有多困难？我的意思是，你认为医学博士对这些综合征有足够的认识，以便在患者身上发现它吗？
And if people are doctor shopping, which often these people will do, can they go undetected for, long periods of time. I actually believe that the majority of these cases go undetected. And a lot of that has to do with a knowledge deficit and an educational deficit among health care providers. It's actually getting better. But I, for example, did my medical school training at Dartmouth and my residency training at Duke. And I never heard the term. factitious or any discussion of munchesom by proxy throughout my education. The first time I heard of it was when I was confronted with a patient in my office who had feigned terminal breast cancer for a year and a half and I suddenly had to do a lot of research on my own to figure out what was happening.
如果人们在“逛医院”（通常这些人会这样做），他们能长时间不被发现吗？我实际上相信大多数这类病例都没有被发现。这在很大程度上与医疗保健提供者的知识缺陷和教育缺陷有关。情况实际上正在好转。但例如，我在达特茅斯完成了医学院培训，在杜克大学完成了住院医师培训。在我的整个教育过程中，我从未听过“虚假”这个词，也没有听到过关于代理性孟乔森综合征的任何讨论。我第一次听说这件事，是在我的办公室里遇到了一位患者，她伪装了晚期乳腺癌一年半，我突然不得不自己做很多研究来弄清楚发生了什么。
She did have a full-blown case of factitious disorder imposed on self. We did call it just plain factitious disorder at the time. But if a patient is particularly crafty, we may see no red flags. And again, as I said before, I think the majority of these cases go unrecognized. So how can an expert differentiate between malingering and hypochondria? I mean, they sound very similar. Are these disorders connected? Are they the same thing? Dr. Cahill? Any thoughts on that? Yes. We do have, as a profession, we've gotten better in our ability to do evaluations that separate those things out.
她确实患有典型的施加于自身的虚假障碍症。当时我们只是称之为单纯的虚假障碍。但如果患者特别狡猾，我们可能看不到任何危险信号。而且，正如我之前所说，我认为大多数这类病例都没有被识别出来。那么，专家如何区分诈病和恐病症呢？我的意思是，它们听起来非常相似。这些疾病有联系吗？它们是同一回事吗？卡希尔博士？对此有什么看法吗？是的。作为一个专业群体，我们在进行能够将这些事情区分开来的评估能力方面有所提高。
So if we have enough information, we can make a distinction between somebody who really feels like their child is having this problem. I'm usually coming from the child perspective, but Mark is right. This can also be just an individual with factitious disorder. So what we need then is we need to get tons of records, and we need to get lots and lots of information, and we have to compare what the potential perpetrator is saying versus what the records are doing. And if we're careful about that and we get enough of the records and we have enough time, we can make the distinction between someone who just is really concerned about their child and messing up to someone who is doing this on purpose.
因此，如果我们有足够的信息，我们就能区分出那些真正觉得自己的孩子有这个问题的人。我通常从儿童的角度出发，但马克是对的。这也可能只是一个患有虚假障碍的个人。所以我们需要的是，我们需要获取大量的记录，我们需要获得许许多多的信息，我们必须比较潜在施害者所说的话与记录所显示的内容。如果我们对此保持谨慎，并获得足够的记录并且有足够的时间，我们就能区分出那些真正关心孩子并把事情搞砸的人与那些故意这样做的人。
So, for example, sometimes if a nurse has a concern, they'll put a camera in the room where the mom is with the child, and we've had a number of these. So you have to get a court agreement for that. You just can't start putting cameras in the hospitals. But let's say we have a camera in the hospital with a mom who says that her child keeps throwing up and he's vomiting and he can't focus anymore. So we look at that after a while and we see that the child is not focusing, but literally the mom is putting a pillow over the case. kid's head and blocking it happens. So there we go. We're set. We know what we're doing. We saw it with our own eyes. Even with that, they will deny to the end of time. It's very difficult to get them to admit they did this. But we have now better protocols where by using the information
所以，举个例子，有时如果护士有担忧，他们会在妈妈和孩子呆的房间里放一个摄像头，我们已经处理过好几个这样的案例了。所以你必须为此获得法院的同意。你不能随随便便就开始在医院里安装摄像头。但假设我们在医院里安装了一个摄像头，里面有一个妈妈，她说她的孩子一直在呕吐，而且他无法集中注意力了。所以过了一会儿我们看了看，发现孩子确实无法集中注意力，但实际上是妈妈把一个枕头放在孩子的头上并捂住——这种情况是会发生的。所以我们就抓到了。我们准备好了。我们知道自己在做什么。我们亲眼目睹了这一切。即便如此，他们也会矢口否认，直到永远。要让他们承认自己做了这件事是非常困难的。但我们现在有了更好的协议，通过利用
we have, it doesn't have to be a camera, but it could be a lot of records, having someone, just a quick example, said her kid keeps throwing up when she goes to school all the time. Talk to the teacher who's there to guard the kids at the school going across the street, she said the kid never throws up. So if we can build a pattern of that, it can't just be one thing, we can make that diagnosis with some accuracy. Dr. Feldman, I want to ask you a question. Back in the 1990s, you coined the term Munchausen by Internet. How has the Internet changed how this disorder presents itself? And is Munchausen by Internet as common as regular Munchausen syndrome, or is it even more common at this point. Well, I coined the term because people, when I lecture it, would often come up to me
我们掌握的信息——不一定非得是摄像头，也可以是大量的记录。举个简单的例子，有人说她的孩子每次去学校时都一直在吐。去问问那个在学校路口护送孩子过马路的老师，她说那个孩子从来不吐。因此，如果我们能够建立这样一个规律，而不能仅仅依靠一件事，我们就可以相当准确地做出诊断。费尔德曼博士，我想问你一个问题。早在20世纪90年代，你创造了“网络孟乔森综合征”（Munchausen by Internet）这个词。互联网是如何改变这种疾病的表现形式的？网络孟乔森综合征像常规的孟乔森综合征那样常见，还是说在这一点上它甚至更常见？嗯，我创造这个词是因为当我做讲座时，人们经常会走到我面前
after the lecture and tell me about online cases. Some of them were so extreme. It was hard to believe that anyone else believe them, but they tend to impart this catastrophic information about illness or crisis in a gradual way that becomes believable because who would think some somebody would go online and lie about their child's health or their own health. And many of the support groups they would log on to are explicitly supportive. They're there to provide health information and health support. They're not there to question anything that goes on. But it can be explosive when it's discovered that a person has lied online, whether about themselves or children.
讲座结束后，向我讲述网络上的案例。其中一些案例是如此极端。很难相信还会有人相信他们，但他们往往会以渐进的方式传授关于疾病或危机的这种灾难性信息，这种信息变得可信，因为谁会认为有人会上网谎报他们孩子的健康状况或他们自己的健康状况呢？他们登录的许多支持小组都是明确支持性的。它们是为了提供健康信息和健康支持而存在的。它们不是为了质疑任何发生的事情。但是，当人们发现有人在网上撒谎时——无论是关于自己还是关于孩子——这可能会引发爆炸性的反应，
and it can often lead to the end of the group because the group members divide into camps of the believers, those who still believe the stories are true, and those who were finished with the group because they know they're not. I think there are way more Munchausen by Internet cases these days than real-life Munchausen cases. Because it used to be that people would have to go to medical libraries, study up about illnesses, then go to an emergency room or a doctor's office and act, really, act out in illness. They had to have acting skills and not everybody does. So sometimes they were detected, sometimes quite easily.
并且往往会导致该小组的解散，因为小组成员会分裂为“信徒”阵营（那些仍然相信这些故事是真的人）和那些与该小组决裂的人（因为他们知道这些故事是假的）。我认为现在网络孟乔森综合征的病例比现实生活中的孟乔森综合征病例要多得多。因为过去人们必须去医学图书馆，研究疾病，然后去急诊室或医生的办公室，并且真正地“表演”出一种疾病。他们必须具备表演技巧，而并非每个人都有。所以有时他们会被发现，有时甚至很容易被发现。
But Munchausen by Internet is different in that it just involves the gift of using words. And you can become an expert in almost any medical ailment by special. spending 20 minutes on Wikipedia. It can include ailments that doctors themselves don't know that much about. And I think, again, if they're discovered, they simply go elsewhere on the internet and may continue the same kind of deception or go into a completely different group, research that one, and try to be credible as they post online. Yeah, Dr. Cahill. Let me add also. I agree everything's Mark Singh, and I think also the Internet has made this more, has increased the number of people who are doing this. Now we have people who have a GoFundMe page for kids' illnesses saying, oh, the kid can't eat, and he has a gastric tube, and he has this and that. They get a lot of attention and positive feedback from people on social media who's saying, oh, you poor thing, we're so sorry.
但网络孟乔森综合征则不同，它只涉及运用文字的天赋。而且只要在维基百科上花20分钟，你就可以成为几乎任何医学疾病的专家。它甚至可以包括医生自己都不太了解的疾病。而且我认为，再次强调，如果他们被发现了，他们只需去互联网的其他地方，并可能继续这种欺诈行为，或者进入一个完全不同的群组，研究那个群组，并试图在网上发帖时显得可信。是的，卡希尔博士。让我再补充一点。我同意马克所说的一切，而且我认为互联网也让这件事变得更普遍了，增加了做这件事的人数。现在我们有人为患病儿童设立GoFundMe筹款页面，说“哦，这孩子不能吃东西，他有胃管，他有这个和那个”。他们在社交媒体上从人们那里获得了很多关注和积极的反馈，人们会说：“哦，你太可怜了，我们太难过了。”
pictures of the kids with masks on and in wheelchairs, those kinds of things. I think it gives them access to a bigger audience that gives them the love and the support that they need. And it's harder in some ways to track them, but in other ways it's easier to track them because we can go on to that website and see what's going on. So I think it's actually increased the number of people who are using or who are doing this against their children because it's another medium that can be very effective for. there's been research in fact that shown that if you compare the child in the hospital and some doctors have done this with what the mother has posted online about the child in the hospital they grossly exaggerate so doctors themselves in hospital staffs if you think it's ethical to look at what the mother is posted online can often make the diagnosis based upon
孩子们戴着口罩坐在轮椅上的照片，诸如此类。我认为这让他们能够接触到更多的受众，从而获得他们所需的爱与支持。在某些方面追踪他们变得更难了，但在其他方面追踪他们变得更容易了，因为我们可以访问那个网站并查看发生了什么。所以我认为这实际上增加了对他们的孩子使用或实施这种做法的人数，因为这是另一种可能非常有效的媒介……事实上，研究表明，如果你把医院里的孩子与母亲在网上发布的关于医院里孩子的言论进行比较，一些医生已经做过这样的研究，你会发现她们极大地夸大了病情。因此，如果你认为查看母亲在网上发布的内容是否符合道德规范，医生自己和医院工作人员往往可以根据
the prose and those pictures that Janet referred to. Some people refer to it as medical pornography. I mean, if you have a desperately ill child, why would you post pictures coming out of orifice, every orifice you can mention, to a group of strangers? Maybe you know a few people, but you don't know others. It's perverse, and it can be an important warning sign. But how can you differentiate between a person who's posting fake information about medical conditions on the internet in order to make money, right? You mentioned a GoFundMe campaign, Dr. Cahill. I mean, but do all of these people really have factitious disorder or are they con artists trying to make money? How can you tell the difference?
珍妮特提到的散文和照片做出诊断。有些人称之为“医疗色情片”。我的意思是，如果你有一个病危的孩子，你为什么要把从孔洞里流出分泌物的照片——你能说出的每一个孔洞——发布给一群陌生人？也许你认识几个人，但其他人你不认识。这是反常的，它可以是一个重要的警示信号。但是，你如何区分一个为了赚钱而在互联网上发布关于医疗状况的虚假信息的人呢？卡希尔博士，你提到了GoFundMe众筹活动。我的意思是，这些人真的都患有虚假障碍吗？还是他们只是为了赚钱而行骗的骗子？你怎么能看出区别呢？
Yeah, that's a very good question. And right, so again, with factitious disorder, the motivation has to be their psychological. needs. If on top of that, they're malingering and getting some money, so they say their kid has ADHD, so they get, you know, they get to send the kid to a certain school or something like that. Or they have nurses. We've had cases where nurses are there 24-7 taking care of the kid for them. We've had cases where they have wheelchairs and they go to, they say the kid is dying, so they get paid to go to Disneyland. These are all real cases. I know. But again, I think we're better with a protocol where we can begin to discriminate those things.
是的，这是一个非常好的问题。没错，对于虚假障碍来说，动机必须是他们的心理需求。如果在此之上，他们还在诈病并获得一些金钱，比如他们说自己的孩子有ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍），这样他们就能让孩子去某所学校或类似的地方。或者他们有护士。我们遇到过这样的案例：护士24/7全天候照顾孩子。我们遇到过这样的案例：他们有轮椅，他们去……他们说孩子快死了，所以他们拿到钱去迪士尼乐园。这些都是真实的案例。我知道。但是，再次强调，我认为我们拥有更好的方案，可以开始区分这些事情。
I'll give you a quick example in a case where I had a mom who's telling me that the kid can't eat. He had autism and had all these problems, but he couldn't eat. So he had go through a number of surgeries and he had a gastric tube and those kinds of things. And the casework I was working with, we did a surprise visit and we walked into the house and we see this kid eating the biggest sandwich we've ever seen in our lives right in front of us. And immediately, oh, yeah. And the mom's like trying to dig herself out of that stuff. So we need to look at what the mom is saying, or the perpetrator,
我给你举个简单的例子，在一个案例中，一个妈妈告诉我这个孩子不能吃东西。他患有自闭症，有各种各样的问题，但他不能吃东西。所以他经历了很多次手术，插了胃管之类的东西。我和处理这个案件的社工进行了一次突击访问，我们走进屋子，看到这个孩子正在我们面前吃着我们一生中见过的最大的三明治。立刻，哦，是的。妈妈试图为自己开脱那些事情。所以我们需要看看妈妈或施害者在说什么，
it can be the father and other people, it can be grandparents. And then we have to compare that to other sources of information. And if we're lucky and if we persevere, we often find those differences. And that's how I would make that diagnosis. I let him finish the sandwich to see you now. I'm sure he thanks you. He appreciates that. There have been cases of mothers starving their children to death.
这可能是父亲和其他人，也可能是祖父母。然后我们必须将其与信息源进行比较。如果我们幸运并且坚持不懈，我们经常能发现这些差异。这就是我如何做出诊断的。我让他吃完三明治，看看你现在。我确信他感谢你。他很感激。曾有母亲活活饿死自己孩子的案例。
There's a famous case in Colorado of a victim who died named Olivia Gant. And there, the mother made up a failure to thrive scenario and made the child sound like she couldn't absorb nutrients. ultimately the child went to hospice and died based upon the mother's instructions that no effort should be made to feed the child. It all is so suspicious as I'm presenting it now, and there were suspicions in the hospital and among a host of health care providers, but they never took the step as mandated reporters to alert child protective services or the police. They kept to quiet. And now they have had, now with the death of the child, they have had to pay millions of dollars for their negligent care that culminated in death and the mother's in prison.
科罗拉多州有一个著名的受害者死亡案例，名叫奥利维亚·甘特（Olivia Gant）。在这个案件中，母亲捏造了一个发育迟缓的场景，让孩子听起来无法吸收营养。最终，根据母亲“不应采取任何努力喂养孩子”的指示，孩子被送往临终关怀院并死亡。我现在这样讲听起来非常可疑，而且在医院和众多医疗保健提供者中也确实存在怀疑，但他们从未作为强制报告员采取步骤去警示儿童保护服务部门或警察。他们保持了沉默。现在，随着孩子的死亡，他们不得不因疏于照顾最终导致死亡而支付数百万美元的赔偿金，而母亲也锒铛入狱。
Dr. Feldman, I listened to a podcast interview you did with a woman who had factitious disorder, but seems to have overcome it. She hasn't made up any illnesses in years. Is that common? And what are the treatments that mental health providers have when they're working with patients who have factitious disorder. Well, it's a challenge. And many people told me when I encountered my first munchausen syndrome or a factitious disorder imposed on self patient that I should just drop the case because that they're needy, they're clingy, they have no desire to get better. That is true in some cases. But I was impressed with the fact that some patients did respond really well. we were able to break through the denial.
费尔德曼博士，我听过你采访过的一位女性的播客节目，她曾患有虚假障碍，但似乎已经克服了它。她已经好几年没有捏造任何疾病了。这很常见吗？当心理健康服务提供者与患有虚假障碍的患者合作时，有哪些治疗方法？嗯，这是一个挑战。当我遇到我的第一个孟乔森综合征或施加于自身的虚假障碍患者时，许多人告诉我，我应该放弃这个病例，因为他们需要照顾、粘人，根本没有想要好起来的愿望。在某些情况下确实如此。但我印象深刻的是，一些患者确实反应非常好。我们能够打破这种否认。
And I found that my lack of overjudgment of them, my sitting with them for two times a week in an hour-long psychotherapy, led them to trust that there, in fact, was a health care provider who cared about them and would be very consistent and not fire them from practice. fire them from the therapy if they happen to slip up. And that's the biggest mistake that therapists make. They tend to say at the beginning, if you do this one more time, harm your child or harm yourself, you're out of here. I'm not going to treat you any further. That never works. It's like saying to a schizophrenic patient, if you have one more hallucination, you're out of here. I mean, it makes no sense. It's just crazy. So in the case I think you're referring to, there were slip-ups where she got hospitalized, but I was there for her. And in fact, she came to recognize that the more she got medical treatment and hospitalizations, the less she could meet with me.
我发现，我没有对他们进行过多的评判，每周陪他们进行两次、每次一小时的心理治疗，让他们相信，实际上确实有一个关心他们的医疗服务提供者，并且会非常一致，不会因为他们偶然失足而将他们从诊所开除。把他们赶出治疗。这是治疗师犯下的最大错误。他们往往在一开始就说：如果你再这样做一次，伤害你的孩子或伤害你自己，你就给我滚蛋。我不会再治疗你了。这永远行不通。这就好比对一个精神分裂症患者说：如果你再产生一次幻觉，你就给我滚蛋。我的意思是，这毫无意义。这简直太疯狂了。所以在我认为你提到的那个案例中，确实出现过失足，她住院了，但我一直在她身边。事实上，她开始认识到，她接受的医疗治疗和住院治疗越多，她能跟我见面的时间就越少。
It was actually interfering with something she was benefiting from. So she gradually abandoned the behavior and is done splendidly. I stay in touch with her, even though it was torn. years ago and she's free of the behavior. So does something like cognitive behavioral therapy work with people who have the disorder, Dr. Cahill? So I'm going to talk specifically about monchasm by proxy. So now we have the parent doing it to the child.
这实际上干扰了她从中受益的事情。所以她逐渐放弃了这种行为，并且做得非常出色。我与她保持着联系，尽管这是几年以前的事了，但她已经摆脱了这种行为。那么，认知行为疗法（CBT）对患有这种疾病的人起作用吗，卡希尔博士？所以我将具体谈谈代理性孟乔森综合征。现在是父母对孩子这样做。
And unfortunately, our track record is very poor. We do have a protocol that was developed by the Apsack group, which is very good. And so it says what we need to do is go through these steps. and trying to treatment them. So ordinary protocols like cognitive behavioral therapy or supportive counseling or behavior therapy does not work with this population. And the problem with the one protocol we have,
不幸的是，我们的成功记录非常糟糕。我们确实有一个由Apsack（美国虐待儿童专业协会）小组制定的方案，非常好。所以它说明了我们需要采取什么步骤。并尝试治疗他们。因此，诸如认知行为疗法、支持性咨询或行为疗法等普通方案对这个群体不起作用。我们拥有的唯一方案的问题在于，
which we've had some very mild successes with, is that the very first step in that protocol is they have to acknowledge that they abuse their child. And we often, and so far, where we get stuck at that one. We can't get past that one. They will not agree that they did something wrong to the child. And there's actually some thoughts out there that if they did it, they really didn't have
我们取得了一些非常轻微的成功，该方案的第一步是他们必须承认自己虐待了孩子。我们经常——到目前为止，我们在这一点上卡住了。我们无法越过这一关。他们不会承认他们对孩子做了错事。甚至有人认为，如果他们真的做了，他们可能就没有
bunchhousin. So if they said, yes, I'm sorry, I did this. They probably don't have bunchhousin. But that's our problem. So the treatment is normal treatment, a really good therapist and the situation that Marchist explained with someone with factitious disorder. Yeah, that's great. But for individuals who truly meet the criteria for proxy, where they're doing this or there's kid, the one protocol we have is not effective because the person will not admit they did anything.
孟乔森综合征。所以如果他们说，是的，对不起，我做了这个。他们可能没有孟乔森综合征。但这正是我们的问题所在。所以治疗是常规治疗，一个真正优秀的治疗师，以及马克针对虚假障碍患者所解释的那种情况。是的，这很好。但对于真正符合代理人标准的个人，即他们对自己或孩子这样做，我们拥有的唯一方案是无效的，因为当事人不会承认他们做了任何事情。
And we can't get past that. If we can get past it, then we can help them to find ways to meet their psychological needs without hurting their children. And there's a few cases where that did happen, but the majority of them, it doesn't work. Yeah, I've done this for 32 years or so and have only had perhaps three patients, or I should say perpetrators who admitted to me what they had done. And they all came through anonymous internet information. I ultimately fanned out their identities. But part of the barrier is what they're doing is illegal in every case. And I think part of the resistance to breaking through the denial is they realized by acknowledging what they're,
我们无法逾越这一点。如果我们能跨过去，那么我们就可以帮助他们找到在不伤害孩子的情况下满足其心理需求的方法。有少数几个案例确实发生了这种情况，但大多数情况下，它并不起作用。是的，我从事这方面工作大约32年了，可能只有三位患者，或者我应该说是施害者向我承认了他们所做的事情。他们都是通过匿名的互联网信息被发现的。我最终查明了他们的身份。但部分阻碍在于，他们在每种情况下所做的事情都是非法的。我认为打破否认的阻力的一部分原因在于，他们意识到通过承认自己所做的事情，
done, they may find themselves criminally prosecuted. So it's a real dilemma. And I'll date myself here. Back in 1994, I published an article called Denial in Munchausen Syndrome by proxy, the consulting psychiatrist dilemma. And we're no further along in having techniques to crack through that denial than we did, honestly, back in 1994. It's getting better. There are lots of ideas, but still, I would totally agree with Janet, that that is a problem that is almost intractable. Is factitious disorder limited to humans, or are there cases where people mistreat their pets, for example? And why would someone do that? I've written quite a bit about that in veterinary journals because I wanted to alert veterinarians,
他们可能会面临刑事起诉。所以这真的是一个两难境地。在这里我要暴露一下自己的年龄了。早在1994年，我发表了一篇名为《孟乔森综合征中的否认：会诊精神病学家的困境》（Denial in Munchausen Syndrome by proxy, the consulting psychiatrist dilemma）的文章。老实说，在拥有打破这种否认的技术方面，我们并没有比1994年取得更多的进展。情况正在好转。有很多想法，但我仍然完全同意珍妮特的观点，这是一个几乎无法解决的问题。虚假障碍仅限于人类吗？或者有没有虐待宠物等案例？为什么会有人这样做？我在兽医期刊上写了相当多关于这方面的文章，因为我想提醒兽医，
and this could happen, and I sent out reprints of the articles, to a bunch of vets that I know. They may indeed, and do, victimize their pets and kill their pets, to extract attention, sympathy, concern. I had one case where the motive was a little bit different. The human taking care of the pet had fallen in love with their vet, and keeping the pet perennially ill allowed her to stay in touch with the the vet. But in other cases, they love the attention or they may get medications prescribed for
这可能会发生，我把我文章的抽印本寄给了一群我认识的兽医。他们确实可能、并且也确实会为了博取关注、同情、关心而残害和杀死他们的宠物。我曾遇到过一个案例，动机略有不同。照顾宠物的人爱上了他们的兽医，让宠物长期生病可以让她与兽医保持联系。但在其他情况下，他们喜欢这种关注，或者他们可能会为宠物开一些药物，
the pet like opioids or benzodiazepines, sedating agents, relaxing agents, and use them themselves. And that becomes a case of malingering by animal proxy. Wow. A few months ago, we did a podcast on pathological lying, and I'm wondering whether people with Munchausen syndrome are dishonest in other parts of their life, and does it co-occur with other mental health disorders? Well, by definition, they are lying and they are doing it on purpose. And often that will spread to other things. They'll, you know, they'll make up other stuff. But most of the energy is towards the child. And but yeah, so they're definitely lying in terms of other things.
比如阿片类药物或苯二氮卓类药物、镇静剂、放松剂，然后自己使用。这就变成了通过动物代理人进行的诈病。哇。几个月前，我们做了一期关于病理性说谎的播客，我想知道患有孟乔森综合征的人在生活中的其他方面是否也不诚实，它是否与其他心理健康疾病同时发生？嗯，根据定义，他们在说谎，而且他们是故意这样做的。通常这种行为会蔓延到其他事情上。他们会，你知道的，他们会捏造其他东西。但大部分精力都花在孩子身上。但是，是的，所以在其他事情上他们肯定也在说谎。
things, yeah, the thing that we have most commonly comorbid, which means the two things occur together, are personality disorders. And so there's a number of those we would use. About 50% of the people who we see who meets criteria for monochasein bioproxy will also have a personality disorder. And we can do both, so we can diagnose both, so we can't, you know, but in terms of, if they have that, let's say, oh, I don't know. example, but let's say they have some depression or anxiety, we would target that secondarily.
事情，是的，我们最常见共病的情况，也就是两件事同时发生的情况，是人格障碍。所以我们要使用其中的好几种。在我们看到的符合代理性孟乔森综合征标准的患者中，大约50%的人也会患有人格障碍。我们可以同时进行这两种诊断，所以我们可以诊断这两种，我们不能……但是，如果他们有那种病，比方说，我不知道。举个例子，假设他们有一些抑郁或焦虑，我们会将其作为次要目标进行治疗。
So first order of business is to see if we can make sure this child is okay, and we would try to treat that, and then we might have to go after the personality disorder later. But generally speaking, again, we don't get there because we can't get past the child abuse. But almost always they'll come in with something else. Dr. Feldman, if you suspect that someone you know may have factitious disorder, and this is for our listeners, what can you do? Are there resources people can go to for help? There really are resources available. I established a website called munchausen.com back in 1993. Again, I'm dating myself more than I intended to. And starting in 1996, I introduced an email capacity. Every day, I hear from people who have one concern or another about medical deception. It is usually a dad or a new wife or the fiancé of the dad who's divorced from his spouse,
因此，首要任务是看我们能否确保这个孩子没问题，我们会尝试治疗这个问题，然后我们可能稍后才去处理人格障碍。但总的来说，再次强调，我们无法做到这一点，因为我们无法越过虐待儿童这一关。但几乎总是，他们会带着其他问题来。费尔德曼博士，如果你怀疑你认识的某个人可能患有虚假障碍，对于我们的听众来说，你能做什么？人们可以去哪里寻求帮助？确实有可用的资源。我在1993年建立了一个名为munchausen.com的网站。再次强调，我暴露年龄的程度超出了我的预期。从1996年开始，我引入了电子邮件功能。每天，我都会收到来自对医疗欺骗有这样或那样担忧的人的来信。通常是一位父亲，或者是与前妻离婚的父亲的新妻子或未婚妻，
looking for munchausen by proxy information and a consultant perhaps to help them along with that. but I do hear from some patients with factitious disorder imposed on self, and I can refer them to a variety of sources. The links on my website help. There are books on the subject, such as my own, Dying to Be Ill and some other earlier ones that I wrote. Dying to Be Ill has the advantage of including personal accounts, tons of personal accounts, from patients who have worked through this or who are experiencing it. And it's written in their own words, so it resonates tremendously with patients.
寻找代理性孟乔森综合征的信息，并可能寻找顾问来帮助他们解决这个问题。但我确实听到过一些患有施加于自身的虚假障碍的患者的来信，我可以将他们推荐给各种资源。我网站上的链接会有所帮助。有一些关于这个主题的书籍，比如我自己的《渴望生病》（Dying to Be Ill）以及我写的一些早期书籍。《渴望生病》的优点在于它包含了患者的个人记述，大量的个人记述，来自那些已经克服了这一点或正在经历这一点的患者。它是用他们自己的话写的，因此与患者产生了极大的共鸣。
And I found that that's been a really helpful tool. And then for Munchausen by proxy cases or medical child abuse cases, there's a website called Munchausen Support.com that was more recently developed and has a wealth of information for anyone, whether professional or not, who might come across one of these cases in their lives. So it includes legal individuals, guardians ad litem, lawyers, but also patients themselves, their families, their friends. So I think that's an important resource.
我发现这真的是一个非常有用的工具。然后对于代理性孟乔森综合征病例或医疗儿童虐待病例，有一个最近开发的名为Munchausen Support.com的网站，该网站为任何人（无论是专业人士还是非专业人士）在其生活中遇到这些病例时提供了丰富的信息。因此，它包括法律人员、诉讼监护人、律师，还有患者本人、他们的家人、他们的朋友。所以我认为这是一个重要的资源。
It doesn't come up easily on Google searches. But again, munchausen Support.com is the site. And Dr. Cahill, what about cases? where somebody thinks a child is being a victim of basically this type of child abuse? My best advice, if you're worried, go do something about it because they're out there. I also just mentioned to the American Professional Society on the Abuse of Children, Apsack, is a very good resource for people to get in touch with. There's a group of people, there's a committee that has expertise in this area.
它在谷歌搜索中不容易搜到。但再次强调，网址是Munchausen Support.com。卡希尔博士，对于那些有人认为某儿童正沦为这种虐待儿童形式的受害者的案件，情况又如何呢？我最好的建议是，如果你担心，就采取行动，因为这样的人就在外面。我还顺便提一下，美国虐待儿童专业协会（Apsack）是人们联系的一个非常好的资源。有一群人，有一个在该领域具有专业知识的委员会。
So that's another place to go to get some help if you need it. I think it's really important. I think people need to get past the idea that how is it possible a parent could do this to their child? It's really hard to get over that bump because how could that possibly happen? So I think one thing to really emphasize is it happens. It's happening out there. So if you have suspicion about that, you should either go to one of the websites that Mark just said or you should call child protection anonymously and not mess around with it and really try to follow up.
所以这是另一个可以寻求帮助的地方。我认为这非常重要。我认为人们需要抛弃这样一种观念：父母怎么可能对自己的孩子做出这种事？要跨过这个坎真的很难，因为这怎么可能发生呢？所以我认为真正需要强调的一点是：它确实发生了。它正在现实中发生。因此，如果你对此有怀疑，你应该要么去马克刚刚提到的网站之一，要么匿名拨打儿童保护热线，不要拖延，真正尝试跟进。
on it. And now I think, you know, child protection is getting more sophisticated about these things. They're following up longer. But don't let it go. If they feel you, if you feel something's going on with that child, call child protection, go on one of these websites. Try to protect that child as any way you can. And if you're wrong, you're wrong. Okay, no problem. If you're right, you're saving that kid's life or they're saving their ability to have a reasonable adulthood. I would also go to the police pretty routinely if it appears that will rise to the level where the police will help. They often know nothing about medical child abuse or factitious disorder, but sometimes there's been grossly illegal behavior. And there is a consultant who's a member of the Apsack team who is a police investigator and international expert in.
现在我认为，你知道的，儿童保护部门对这些事情越来越成熟了。他们跟进的时间更长了。但不要放过它。如果你觉得那个孩子身上发生了什么，拨打儿童保护热线，访问这些网站。尽你所能保护那个孩子。如果你错了，那就错了。好吧，没关系。如果你是对的，你就在拯救那个孩子的生命，或者他们拥有合理成年生活的机会。如果情况严重到警察可以提供帮助的程度，我通常也会直接报警。他们通常对医疗儿童虐待或虚假障碍一无所知，但有时存在严重非法的行为。Apsack团队中有一位顾问是一名警察调查员，也是该领域的国际专家。
medical child abuse in particular. And he's always willing to consult for free with police departments that might encounter a case. And he tells them exactly what to do every step of the way. It's good to know there are resources out there. So last question, Munchausen syndrome and Munchausen by proxy have been dramatized in TV and movies probably because so many of these stories are compelling, if not downright horrifying. Do you think these portrayals are giving the public an accurate picture of these disorders, or are they misleading? Okay.
尤其是医疗虐待儿童。他总是愿意为可能遇到此类案件的警察局提供免费咨询，并且一步一步地告诉他们具体该怎么做。很高兴知道有这样的资源。最后一个问题，孟乔森综合征和代理性孟乔森综合征经常在电视和电影中被戏剧化，可能是因为其中许多故事非常引人入胜，甚至可以说是骇人听闻。你认为这些 portrayal 向公众提供了这些疾病的准确写照，还是具有误导性？好的。
I think they're helpful overall, if they're well done, in educating the public. And they've particularly shown cases of Munchausen by proxy. But they do, as you might expect on a true crime program on TV, or a fictionalized case of Munches and By proxy stressed the most extreme and dramatic cases like the Gypsy Rose Blanchard case where she had her boyfriend kill her mother as a way to finally escape
我认为总的来说，如果制作精良的话，它们对教育公众是有帮助的。它们尤其展示了代理性孟乔森综合征的案例。但是正如你对电视上的真实犯罪节目或代理性孟乔森综合征的虚构案例所预料的那样，它们确实强调了最极端、最具戏剧性的案件，比如吉普赛·罗斯·布兰查德（Gypsy Rose Blanchard）的案件，她让男友杀了自己的母亲，以此作为最终逃脱的手段
the abuse she had encountered for 19 or 20 years as a result of Munchesom by proxy and having to play along with her mother's efforts to depict her. as ill. And obtaining money was a big piece of that. Jipsy Rose, the daughter, is now in prison, but we'll probably get out next year or the year after. She was convicted of second-degree murder, even though she didn't wield the knife. Her boyfriend, who did, is sentenced to life in prison, I think, without the possibility of parole. But Gypsy Rose has said that her life in prison
她因代理性孟乔森综合征而遭遇了 19 或 20 年的虐待，并且不得不配合她母亲将她描绘成病人的做法。获取金钱是其中很大的一部分。女儿吉普赛·罗斯目前在监狱里，但可能会在明年或后年出狱。她被判二级谋杀罪，尽管她没有亲自拿刀。那个动手的男友被判处终身监禁，我想，是不得假释的那种。但吉普赛·罗斯曾表示，她在监狱里的生活
is much more liberating and free than what she encountered under her mother and that she doesn't really regret what happened. Yeah, I would add to that, yeah. I mean, I think getting over the hump that this could happen, I'm all for that. I agree that some of these are pretty dramatic and pretty crazy, and they're missing the little ones where they're not just doing these dramatic things. But anything that encourages people to understand that it is possible that this disorder exists I think is helpful for us.
比她在母亲手下遭遇的生活要解放和自由得多，而且她并不真正后悔发生的一切。是的，我要补充一点，是的。我的意思是，我认为跨越“这种事竟然会发生”这道坎，我完全支持这一点。我同意其中一些案件相当戏剧化、相当疯狂，而且它们忽略了那些没有做出如此戏剧化举动的较小案件。但任何能鼓励人们理解这种疾病确实可能存在的举措，我认为对我们都有帮助。
Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. This is an absolutely fascinating topic. I really appreciate you taking the time. Thank you so much for having us. My pleasure. Thanks for having us. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts.
好的，我要感谢两位今天能来到这里。这是一个绝对引人入胜的话题。非常感谢你们抽出时间。非常感谢邀请我们。这是我的荣幸。感谢邀请我们。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org，或者在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 以及您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》以前的单集。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 Speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学对话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音响编辑是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Kondyenne）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学协会。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。